c'est une image devenue courante ces
dernières semaines des étagères des
garnis dans des pharmacies de plusieurs
régions du pays ici en Mauricie la
pénurie de médicaments se poursuit
lorsqu'on vit c'est toutes nos sirops
pour la toux pour la grippe nos
comprimés pour la toux on n'est pas
capable de rien se procurer on reçoit ça
à coup de 5 6 boîtes une fois de temps
en temps ça dure 24 heures sur nos
tablettes c'est déjà vide la production
n'est pas en cause mais plutôt un
système d'approvisionnement domestique
vulnérable et une demande qui a explosé
trois quatre fois plus de médicaments
contre le rhume et la grippe cette année
qu'habituellement une situation aggravée
par des achats de panique et le stockage
il faut examiner des facteurs atténuants
pour une meilleure gestion des
approvisionnements estiment
l'association des pharmaciens de
l'Ontario ils sont nombreux à demander à
Ottawa de se doter d'une stratégie
maintes et maintes fois une pénurie se
produit nous nous efforçons tous faire
face puis nous passons à autre chose ce
que nous aimerions voir c'est un plan
d'action plus complet pour prévenir les
pénuries indique l'association des
pharmaciens du Canada
suggèrent notamment de tenir une liste
de tous les médicaments essentiels et de
les monitoris sans arrêt pour augmenter
la production nationale ou procéder à
des importations s'il y a des risques de
pénurie plutôt que d'attendre que les
étagères soient vides le ministre
fédéral de la Santé dit suivre la
situation de près et que son bureau et
Santé Canada sont en discussion avec des
fabricants au Canada et à l'étranger le
problème n'est toutefois pas unique au
pays les États-Unis la France et la
Grande-Bretagne rapportent aussi des
problèmes d'approvisionnement en
pharmacie en raison d'une saison de
maladies respiratoires très virulente
ici Camille Faye zen Radio-Canada
Montréal